[Music]
okay so we just passed kb stores which
is great kb's toy store is where you
went when all the other places didn't
have the video game you wanted and you
hoped that maybe they did
oh it was like it's like yeah okay there
it is the holy grail
it's the holy grail we were not
worthy we let me tell you something
let me tell you something this is
this is the holy grail nobody will
ever ever ever
ever tell me this wasn't the best store
ever
[Music]
mom you're going shopping that's okay
i'll be at spencer gifts oh
what will i be doing there you ask oh
i'll be looking at t-shirts and
casually wandering to the back to look
at the naked girls
that's correct i'm sorry did you want a
calendar that was made of a bunch of
little baby dildos
you have that at spencer hey
do you want a store where you can get a
sublime t-shirt and
a penis straw that's spencer's gift
you walk into spencer's and it just
lights up and they put like
they put like a robe on you and they go
sir would you like to go see the fake
dog poop or the fake vomit section
excuse welcome to spencer's gift sir
[Music]
may i may i delight you with
a wide array of sex toys and
doormats that say i'm not as think as i
drunk i
am would you like to ignore your
roommate
by having something that makes a smoke
alarm
when it's not really going off well come
over here to our prank
section this soap
no ordinary soap for it makes your hands
black when you use it
brows our collections of stink bombs
[Laughter]
and did we mention we have sublime
shirts
[ __ ]
[ __ ] love it it's the best store ever
did your religious father tear down your
x-files poster
we've got that
do you want sunglasses in the shape of
tits
spencer gibbs has you covered
why we should have hired us we would
have [ __ ] made a great commercial
it'd still be open it's [ __ ] we'll
[ __ ] be killing it right now man
oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] want to impress your lady
buy a two beer or not to be a shirt
right over here
are you a chronic masturbator don't go
in our blacklight section
[Music]
me too i think the point is that i love
jesus christ
[Music]
you don't know what you got till it's
gone man
spence's gift something you find funny
and throw away as soon as you get home
[Music]
spencer's gift give your wife expired
penis gummies
this anniversary oh i see you're
browsing our food section
no that's not regular pasta that's
dick-shaped pasta
[Music]
which immediately falls apart when you
cook it
oh [ __ ] spencer's gift
america the store
do you want a piddle do you want a pill
bottle filled with candy that says
[ __ ] pills take one per day
do you want a man that blows bubbles out
of his beer bottom
we have that at spencer's gift
where else can you find many various
sizes of
whoopee cushion you hear that noise
oh that's not a fart that is a prank
um oh [ __ ]
spencer's gift we're like hot topic
except not as gay
spencer's gifts are you edgy but not
that edgy
oh [ __ ] god damn that was fun
it's pence's gift we're like the
internet exploded in 1995.
spencer's gift reddit the store
[Music]
spencer's gift what's reddit
eric in the chat spencer's gift it's the
hot topic for kids in a two-parent
household
and says gifts please help us we are
stuck in a time loop
help help us please every day is torture
help spencer's gift remember daria
we do
prince's gifts where else will you find
beavis
and bud head
okay
[Music]
okay okay all right okay i gotta stop
spencer's gift we have the early south
park joke shirts
[Music]
okay all right i'm done i'm starving
we're
done okay all right okay okay
hey uh h is somebody tell a g to please
clip that
that bit because that was very good and
it was very very happy
how far away the show i'll even give him
a time stamp uh how far
we were in i'm sorry
you gotta make me laugh so hard i'm
coughing 50 minutes in
holy [ __ ] eric hold on one more one more
sorry
sorry i know it's over we should have
moved up but hold on
eric eric hanson in the chat spence's
gift
because y2k is coming for you
spencer's gifts where else will you find
bacon flavored lubricant
[Music]
all right just thinking of the worst
novelty items in existence
okay i'm gonna tell him right now so he
doesn't forget because i'll forget
i'm gonna message a.g
please clip the spencer's gift segment
we did on day wave today 50 minutes in
perfect okay i don't want i don't want
to forget because that was good
[ __ ] i go blind with a laugh that's hard
[ __ ] i know me too
dude it was [ __ ] god damn
all right listen 54 seconds
oh my god oh my god no we're only 54
seconds into this video
time is time is
time just a concept to you here it's
spencer's gift
sweet get lost
oh [ __ ] man holy [ __ ]
okay hold on people are saying i forgot
this was a video so did i
we just brought up a picture of spain
remember spencer's gift
all right we're going to continue the
video let me please let's see if we've
got some donations through this
oh my god just because i got to say
[Music]
uh sweet tooth uh browser out of variety
of dick pops
sweet tooth brows a variety of dick pops
here at spencer's gift
i think the accents we were doing is
what made it the most fun
we're at 79 dollars by the way because i
know the thing at the bottom fancy a
snack
we have [ __ ] salami
looking for something for your honda
civic we have
he who smelted delted bumper stickers
um okay we're moving i'm pressing play
okay let's play
first player i'll keep going i have like
eight more so do i
for example for example for example we
also have bumper stickers that say
unless you're a hemorrhoid get off my
ass
freshen up your car
i love that we're making spencer's gifts
so regal
it was it not
by the way guys now i always plug a
dana's show but i'll plug in the middle
of it you really guys should be watching
joy of pesky show he's [ __ ] hilarious
as you can see he is great stuff
criminally under subbed on d live i'm
pretty sure i'm pretty sure i saw helen
mirren
at a spencer's gift it's regal as [ __ ]
yes
you mean dame helen mirren yes
dame helen dench judy i'm looking for
something for my grandchild
i'm looking for something i can
comedically cram in my
they unlock a secret backdoor just for
the celebs at spencer